okay Merrill I'm in Los Angeles shooting  with GQ magazine who's the last person  on earth I would go on a date with a lot  of football players I wouldn't date any  of them that's too close to home my dad  wouldn't like that very much  oh let's talk about dates I'm like  getting really hungry I want like a  veggie burger and fries and a glass of  wine and to talk about politics with  somebody  Zoe didn't invite her date inside she  just told him honestly if I was gonna  [ __ ] you you know I think that's good  advice do what Zoe Barnes would do know  what other things you shouldn't talk  about on a first date I say you talk  about whatever I mean you want the  person to get to know you right  you  you